sie wollten und konnten nicht nur
zuschauen beim ukraine krieg sie sich
aufgemacht nach kiew um präsident selenz
geht zu treffen dieses eu trio aus polen
aus tschechien aus slowenien dort dann
dem ukrainischen präsidenten hand
geschüttelt ist war muss man sagen eine
historische mission sich in diesen
kriegszeiten aufzumachen mitten ins
zentrum des kriegs gibt und alle drei
bewegende worte danach gefunden mit dem
ukrainischen präsidenten zu lenz geht
das noch mal die bilder von dort alle in
ja arbeitsklamotten sozusagen in
pullover teilweise in militär klamotten
dort sich getroffen sich zusammengesetzt
gemeinsam die karten der ukraine
angeschaut und dann eben nach diesen
handshakes vor den mikrofonen der welt
jedoch der polnische vize premier
kaczynski bewegende worte gefunden
schauen wir mal rein
sie kämpfen um ihr leben und ihre
freiheit aber wir wissen dass sie auch
um unser leben und unsere freiheit und
frieden
alle die von putin getötet wurden die
können und werden niemals vergessen
seien der notfall würde diese nicht
allein ihr kampf ist unser kampf und
zusammen schaffen wir das
lama ukraine jetzt sprechen wir darüber
mit power an zweimal unserem bild
reporter nie krieges hauptstadt schönen
guten morgen paul bleibt es bei diesen
worten oder und matt dieser besuch etwas
bewegt in der ukraine
was er bewirkt hat das wird sich zeigen
müssen denn nur eines bewegt die
menschen hier kai dass dieser krieg
aufhört und bislang hat der krieg nicht
aufgehört es hat wieder explosion
gegeben auch hier in kiel für haben ein
einschlag gesehen ist noch unklar ob
dort ob dort opfer wird es dort zivile
opfer gibt in anderen teilen der ukraine
wütet der krieg weiter und denn auch
dieser respekt verlangt natürlich auch
vielen ukrainern großen respekt ab ich
habe gestern nacht noch mit vitali
klitschko lange telefonieren können und
mit ihm über diesen besuch gesprochen
und er war auch sichtlich bewegt davon
dass diese beiden regierungschefs den
weg gemacht haben hier in seiner stadt
und man darf nicht vergessen keine
situation in einer stadt die wirklich
heikel ist heute zum beispiel dürfen wir
nicht mehr vor die tür auch tagsüber
denn es herrscht eine komplette
ausgangssperre und es bedeutet bis auf
ausnahmen diejenigen die auf der straße
sind die könnten der fenster
36 stunden ausgangssperre paul schilder
uns einmal die situation noch in kiew
gestern haben wir gesprochen und wurde
schon in der früh geweckt von
einschlägen von explosionen und dass uns
dann den tag über zerstörte wohnblöcke
in der hauptstadt gezeigt jetzt kannst
du nicht raus kannst diese bilder uns
nicht zeigen aber wie ist dein eindruck
dort als sowas gehört beschreibt uns
einmal wie die stadt jetzt der jetzt
hätten in dieser angespannten stimmung
die politiker sind weg die
ausgangssperre bleibt umgehen
ja das ist ein bisschen die sorge dass
möglicherweise eben nach dem besuch
jetzt wo die regierungschefs weggehen
ist wieder zu einem heftigeren angriff
kommen könnte das ist das auch was
einige hier vermuten es hat dennoch in
der nacht ein schläge gegeben wie gesagt
wir wissen dass ein ziel definitiv
getroffen wurde auch hier in kiew was
das bedeutet welche konsequenzen das hat
das müssen wir jetzt recherchieren da
gibt es noch keine klaren zahlen noch
ein wort zu diesem besuch dieses eu
trios der drei regierungschefs aus polen
tschechien slowenien dort bei selensky
in kiew paul danach ist von einer nato
friedensmission zum ersten mal die rede
die hat der vize premier kaczynski von
polen ins spiel gebracht ist das so ein
wort das jetzt eine dynamik entwickeln
könnte oder hirngespinst wird nichts
draus
ich halte eine nato friedensmission für
relativ unrealistisch muss ich sagen
angesichts der tatsache dass sowohl joe
biden als olaf scholz und emanuel makro
ein wie auch immer geartetes eingreifen
beziehungsweise ein eintreten der nato
hier in den krieg ausgeschlossen haben
und das sind dann doch die
entscheidenden stimmen dabei
beziehungsweise wenn nur ein land in der
nato dagegen wäre wäre ist schon kaum
möglich ich glaube nicht daran dass das
eine chance hat dennoch präsident
selensky versucht verzweifelt weiter
darauf hinzuweisen dass jeden tag hier
menschen sterben hunderte tausende
zivilisten bereits ukraine rinnen und
ukraine und nicht nur ukraine haben das
gestern erlebt dass erneut auch ein
journalist gestorben ist ein kollege von
uns ein kameramann den wir hier bei dem
orden an dem wir gerade sind jeden
morgen getroffen haben
und ich habe heute morgen geschrieben
bei twitter weil es mir so den kopf kam
heute können wir nicht mehr gut morning
zu ihm sagen
der kameramann jahre lang unterwegs auch
als kriegsreporter der auch mit dir
zusammen dort ihr stand noch neben ihnen
vor zwei wochen glaube ich auch paul hat
soll auch ein foto gepostet von einer
pressekonferenz dort mit seelands gehe
und die arbeit der journalisten dort ist
deutlich schwieriger geworden und das
sieht man auch daran dass wir jeden tag
diese bildung der zerstörung der
anschläge der explosionen hier bekommen
dass derzeit die lage in der ukraine in
kiew in der hauptstadt zusammengefasst
von paul ronzheimer vielen herzlichen
dank dir
und gestern dann der besuch des trios
jetzt aber jetzt sind die politiker weg
dennoch es war ein historisches zeichen
und so bewertet das auch ukraine ist
präsidentiellen ski
ich möchte mich bei ihnen für ihre
unterstützung bedanken es ist eine zeit
in der sogar botschafter unser land
wegen des krieges verlassen haben und
diese wichtigen regierungsvertreter hier
sind zu uns gekommen das ist ein sehr
mutiger schritt und ein beachtenswertes
zeichen was ich bin sicher dass wir mit
solchen nachbarn und partnern weit
kommen können aber am wichtigsten ist
dass wir diesen menschen glauben deshalb
sprechen wir über sicherheitsgarantien
über unsere zukunft in der eu und über
sanktionen wir wissen zu 100 prozent
dass das worüber wir hier sprechen
realisiert werden wird
dass das eine treffen in kiew darauf
dass die welt geschaut hat dass der drei
regierungschefs aus osteuropa dort
dieser mutigen europäer die nicht länger
stillhalten wollten die sich auf den weg
gemacht haben direkt nach ihr zu ihrem
kollegen zielinski das andere treffen
auf das haben wir vergangene woche
geschaut gerd schröder in moskau bei
putin kann dieses treffen was bewegen
kann dieser mann der sich von putin
bezahlen lässt tatsächlich in diesem
konflikt vermitteln was ist jetzt raus
gekommen der ukrainische botschafter in
deutschland findet für dieses treffen
klare worte andere manager sagt hierzu
bild auch wenn diese hoffnung auf diese
persönliche initiative von herrn
schröder von anfang an klitzeklein war
ist die enttäuschung trotzdem groß dass
er wirklich gar nichts gar nichts
konkretes oder hilfreiches zu berichten
hatte dieser vorstoß sagt ukraine
botschafter hat sich leider gottes als
komplett ergebnislos und wohl auch als
sinnlos erwiesen das sind knallharte
worte richtung dieses treffens von gerd
schröder bei vladimir putin
ja das sagt der kreml sprecher dimitri
peskow dazu er sagt ich habe keine
informationen über schröder ich kann
ihnen nicht sagen und in der
zwischenzeit ist hier sehen wir dass die
tat noch mal also dann tut mir das heißt
so im kreml es war überhaupt was war er
denn überhaupt da
es hat nichts gebracht außer spesen
nichts gewesen paul ronzheimer noch
einmal zugeschaltet aus der ukraine aus
kiew außer spesen nichts gewesen dieser
besuch von gerd schröder bei wladimir
putin der ist hoch gesetzt worden als
möglicher vermittlungsversuch hier
steckt hoffnung drin gerd kann den
frieden bringen nichts was davon es hat
vor allen dingen wahrscheinlich ihm
selbst genutzt paul
gar nichts war es und du sprichst es an
hoch wie jetzt von ihm persönlich also
dass dieser besuch aus kam das lag nicht
an den ukrainern oder an den russen
davon gehe ich zumindest aus sondern an
gerhard schuler selbst der das ganze
gestreut hat und wenn man jetzt hier mit
ukraine anspricht wenn man auch mit
beratern im umfeld von salans gespräch
dann sagen sie das war ein pr auf kosten
der ukraine und ihr habt gerade schon
die deutlichen worte von anderem eine
demokratie mission botschafter der
diplomat ist aber auch sehr sehr klar
sein kann und der hat gesagt es hat gar
nichts gebracht er hat sich nämlich
briefen lassen von dem ukrainischen
abgeordneten der das mit unter anderem
schröder organisiert hat bzw den er
getroffen hat eine pro-russische
abgeordneter muss man dazu sagen und er
hat erfahren was dort gesprochen wurde
und er sagt davon da gab es gar nichts
gleichzeitig haben wir dann auch
gespräche so konnte gestern peter tiede
herausfinden mit roman abramowitsch
stattgefunden dem oligarchen der dann in
moskau auch gelandet ist und wir haben
uns hier immer wieder gefragt welche
rolle könnte er spielen er wurde
zeitweise vor einigen tagen sogar
gefordert als unterhändler von sie
lenski gleichzeitig er natürlich auch
sein geld gemacht durch putin jetzt also
eine ganz zentrale figur plötzlich
geworden wie schätzt du da sein
ich schätze es so an dass den ukrainern
das relativ egal ist wer jetzt in diesen
tagen alles mit gerhard schröder spricht
sie haben ein ziel direkte gespräche
selent ski und putin das ist das ziel
des ukrainischen präsidenten direkte
verhandlungen auf augenhöhe
und wenn roman abramowitsch das
erreichen kann dann ist das gut das
gleiche hätte für werth schröder
gegolten wenn etwas funktioniert hätte
da ist man hier überhaupt nicht
dogmatisch und da sagt der gern schröder
hat jetzt ausschließlich für gazprom
gearbeitet deswegen trauen wir dem nicht
natürlich traut ihm niemand aber wenn er
es geschafft hätte dann wäre es positiv
gewesen so muss man aber sagen das war
ein pr termin was jetzt andere erreichen
können wird man sehen aber es ist für
die ukraine wichtig dass diese
verhandlung schnell stattfinden damit
nicht noch hunderte tausende weitere
menschen sterben müssen